what do you think about what's going on
with yay right now
hey man I don't have no say so in that
how did that like initially happen you
guys working together
well
this was on my 18th birthday he had
called me
um Six Flags for 18th birthday present
Kanye calls you yeah it was my 18th
birthday I was throwing this huge
mansion party and I just get this random
phone call yeah
that's yeah he's like yo I got some [__]
for you I'm like let's get it I was
shroomed out that day I was shrooming
balls nice I was out of it and then bro
we just grabbed the studio equipment it
wasn't even though like you know how
like a big Studio big Studio there's not
no [__] Mike knows Sony c100 we just
grabbed we literally had a 500 mic wow
put in a small room
lay down the Verge send it back to him
that [__] was crazy and I was like same
night while you're streaming hard well
I'm shrooming so you record that while
you're [__] shroomed out yeah